Washington DC the seat of power looking
like a war zone
protesters ignoring the curfew met with
flashbacks rubber bullets and tear gas
just a few minutes away from the White
House in New York more mayhem Macy's an
icon of the American high street
ransacked by looters
but a clampdown did reduce the carnage
led by a telling presidential pledge I
will fight to protect you
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of all peaceful protesters even
[Music]
before the curfew outside the reality of
that promise played out the crowds
aggressively dispersed soon after the
path was clear for a stunning moment of
political theater the president
clutching a Bible at an historic church
damaged by fire today apoplectic pastors
accused him of using us as a cynical
prop to them it felt like a haunting
return to a deeply traumatic era in
American life even for horses out here
he used the military and clear people
out as if we were in the 1960s with the
civil rights movement in Philadelphia
mr. Trump's political rival pitched the
prospect of a starkly different country
but I promise you this
I won't traffic in fear and division
I won't fan the flames of hate I'll seek
to heal the racial wounds that have long
plagued our country not use them for
political gain it is promising not to be
Donald Trump enough what the president
can legitimately say is the city now
looks a lot more kana and it seems far
less violence even with that it doesn't
have to hurt him
political ascendancy has been dominated
by division what could make the
difference in 2020 is just how diverse
the electorate is and how willing they
are to get their voices heard one thing
is for certain this country is still
consumed by unrest and there's a burning
anger it may be very hard to extinguish
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington